hi there steve here i've come back from
my skiing i'm going to do another video
about language systems to follow up on
the earlier one
um just a little before i get started uh
just to brag a bit about vancouver uh 25
minutes from my home i can go skiing
there was three or four meters of snow
there great big trees one meter in
diameter great tall
douglas fir trees cypress trees
it was sunny then we had a little bit of
a snow flurry and there's trails
everywhere there's also downhill skiing
but i prefer the cross country
and while i was up there my wife was off
playing golf which is also 25 minutes
from my home
so it's kind of nice that way
now i was talking about language
learning systems i talked about pimsleur
and sml and and so forth and most of the
systems deal with getting people started
and uh i think there it really almost
doesn't matter what you do the objective
is to get away from the learner the
learning type content and get to real
content as quickly as you can i think
for
most european languages western european
languages three months is enough for
russian maybe six months for asian
languages maybe nine months
you want to get on to
real content as soon as possible
i didn't talk much about rosetta stone
because i haven't used it my son used it
he didn't like it
it's quite expensive it's 300 or
whatever it is 250
it doesn't cover very much
uh you're obliged to sit by the computer
there's lots of pictures and games and
god knows what can content
so i don't think it's a very good
investment i would rather
spend thirty dollars to buy a teach
yourself book or a colloquial book to
get past that initial stage
uh plus the rosetta stone has you
spending a lot of time in front of the
computer uh i would say i spent 80 or 90
percent of my language learning time
away from the computer either reading or
listening
uh obviously you know i've talked about
this before the the ipod in particular
the ipod shuffle let's see in front of
the computer here
is is an ideal little tool uh while i
was up uh skiing
i was listening to content in russian i
was listening to content in italian
uh there's so much wonderful content
on the internet news content history
content old radio programs uh il
gastronouta from rai on on food in italy
and i was listening to
20 year old radio programs but marco
polo in italian and stuff now
they're not all as well organized for
the language learner as ekamuskvi
in that they don't provide transcripts
we are approaching some
podcasters and asking them to
to let us provide them with transcripts
in exchange for them in exchange for
which they then talk about link which
has been
moderately successful
let's see uh what else can i talk about
um
books yeah once therefore once you get
past
the uh the sort of beginner stage you're
now into different kinds of readers
um this was an intermediate book that i
used for uh for my korean and i didn't
like it uh the content was boring lots
of unnecessary explanation
and and one of the reasons why i stopped
uh doing korean and went on to russian
is that um there was really not very
much interesting content available for
korean
russian i've bought a number of
different books here's an example of how
not to do that next stage
it's it's a it's called advanced russian
through history
interesting content very interesting
contract very well written
but they just
take
what could be an excellent book like
interesting content about russian
history and they go about
making people dislike it
first of all they're very proud of the
fact that the cd that comes with it is
not the same as the texts
now why
so when i listened to this when i you
know a year and a half ago when i
started on this i would listen to cd i
wouldn't understand very much
and it wasn't the same as the text so i
couldn't get that
sim beyond the symbiotic synergy
synergistic benefit of listening to the
same stuff as i'm reading
and they've got
you know all kinds of preface for the
students how to make this uh
an uninteresting thing to do
they you know
each chapter is accompanied by learning
tasks
to make sure you don't like it as ruben
alves says nothing destroys the
enjoyment of reading as much as being
asked to analyze or describe what you've
just been listening to
and they have a list of of 25
tasks that you're supposed to do
learning tasks here
for pre-reading tasks
read guided questions in english to
prepare to read the chapters task
what else here they've got read
alphabetically sequence lists of
historical geographical political terms
then they've got
map locate important places on a map
answer general comprehension questions
in english all before you read it come
on get serious
reading tasks
identify the ideological perspective of
the author i mean i'm reading about
genghis khan
you know what i choose to take out of
the reading is is maybe i hear the the
sound of of horses hooves on the steps
as the
mongol horde is attacking the russians
or something
i don't want to worry about the ideology
of the writer
then they got a bunch of stuff find
words in the text with given roots and
analyze given words by roots
you know and it just goes on and on and
that's only number seven of their 25
you know work with pronouns and
antecedents
translate this
rewrite sentences
just just goes on and on 25 learning
tasks the wrong thing to do
i
enjoyed
the text would have been better with
sound i enjoyed the cd it took me a long
time before i could
understand it
i would have loved to have had the
e-text of that i would have imported it
into link i would have saved all those
words and phrases to my database i would
have reviewed them
all this business about roots and
suffixes and prefixes
yeah i've got thousands of words saved
in link i can search by suffixes and
prefixes when i want to not as part of a
deliberate you know list of tasks that i
have to do that are going to destroy my
enjoyment of the text so that was that
really then i think when we're talking
about systems let me just then go over
again what i think is important
the internet is is is actually is going
to r has revolutionized and and more and
more will revolutionize language
learning you can get
uh
seminars lectures i mean these wonderful
italian lectures on italian history on
ancient history on the history of modern
history of of rome from the 1880s
through the first world war second world
war
uh now they don't all have transcripts
but that's going to come
and so we ask those access those on the
internet we have tools on the internet
to help us through them in the old days
if i had to read something
i needed a word list
or i had to read something where there's
only a small percentage of new words
that's no longer the case i can get at
it get my online dictionary work my way
through it listen to it a few times
you know get to where i kind of half
know it then i take my ipod shuffle up
skiing i take it uh
you know while i'm doing the dishes and
i learn or
uh you know as in the case of the
kreuzer sonata i i do a lot of listening
this is one of the reasons why i was
able to get onto this very early in my
studies is that i got an excellent audio
book in in regal latvia in russian
the voice was excellent i enjoyed
listening to it i listened to it many
many many times so i was able to go
through the text on link get all the
words into my database review them i was
able to read it in in you know a nice
comfortable book format and i was able
to listen to it now one day
when they enable these ebook readers
like kendall and the sony ebook reader
to the point where they have
uh a lot of the functionality that we
have
i mean maybe i won't i don't know maybe
i like reading it on i'll have with me
my little ebook reader
with all of my link functionality
and
quick access like again here on the
internet yeah i have trouble with my
cases and declensions and stuff i have
that
you know saved a favorite i can go to a
site where i can see these declensions
and that all helps me so there's a whole
range of resources that are available
via the internet with modern technology
that makes all these other textbooks uh
obsolete and and increasingly i think
will convince people that they don't
have to go to a school to learn that
it's more
uh important to commit yourself to
learning
uh with interesting content so there you
have it i
kind of wanted a bit but i hope that was
uh useful to you thank you bye for now